good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight loudoun county virginia
right outside washington dc
was for a very long time for generations
a reasonable place
it was orderly and calm it was well
maintained
louden county famously worked certainly
in contrast to the city
nearby and then two things happened to
loudoun county
first lots of federal money flowed in
all those government contracts in
washington
made laden county rich in fact loudoun
county is now the single richest county
in the entire united states and that's
been a problem because any place you
find easy money you will also inevitably
find
large numbers of unhappy white liberals
those brittle neurotics with the masks
on screaming at everyone else to get in
line
louden county has a whole bunch of those
people now
it also has a huge number of immigrants
one out of every four people in loudoun
county was born in another country
now in general most immigrants are not
very liberal
at all actually in fact many of them
have what would now be described as
extreme
right-wing positions on social issues if
you ever have a chance ask a salvadoran
what he thinks of
transgenderism it'll make you laugh
probably nervously you'll look around
and see if anyone heard it
but as a practical matter it doesn't
matter at all
what immigrants what salvadorans or
pakistanis
think of social issues or how they
organize their own families
immigrants vote overwhelmingly for the
democratic party and those votes give
more power not to them
but to those unhappy white liberals who
want to blow everything up
and that's why mystery solved a lot of
places with high levels of recent
immigrants tend to be far more liberal
than those immigrants themselves
it's interesting and that's definitely
true in loudoun county virginia
take a look at the schools if you don't
believe it loudoun county used to have
famously good schools people wanted to
send their kids to those schools
now those schools are run by lunatics
who hate the country
it happened fast it always does here's
video from a county school board meeting
just two days ago
the first person you're going to see in
this video is a middle school teacher
called andrea weiskopf
now as you watch this keep in mind that
andrea weiskopf is actually a middle
school teacher she's not a paid actor
we didn't make her up to prove a point
she is entirely
real down to the ostentatiously
displayed pronouns
in her twitter bio here's miss weiskopf
explaining how the book to kill a
mockingbird
a book the rest of us assumed was all
about why racism is bad
is in fact itself racist because it
causes something called
racial trauma due to the fact there are
white people in it
it's funny how they are so afraid of
their children seeing
another view of sexuality
gender or religion if you want to talk
about books that
are assigned let's read to kill a
mockingbird together
if you aren't willing to consider the
racial trauma
this assigned book causes black children
with its white saver
saviorism then you have no business
discussing any books
oh so if you don't consider to kill a
mockingbird
racist says andrea weiskopf then quote
you have no business discussing
any books can you even imagine what this
lady's personal life must be like
miserable does not even begin to
describe it desperate
hellish but if she somehow looks
familiar there's a reason for that
you've heard a lot of lectures like this
recently from people like andrea
weiskopf
stupid people telling you what you're
allowed to say and read
that's essentially 2021 summed up in a
single sentence
the scariest part is they're telling
your kids the exact same thing
all day every day in school
so what effect is that having on your
kids on all of our kids on the country
itself
well over time the effect is
unimaginable for the last year most
parents have put up with this
either they didn't know it was happening
or they felt powerless to stop it from
happening
they were afraid to object to speak up
as lunatics like andrea weiskopf
hurt their children but that's changing
finally some parents have had enough of
this watch
this mother at this week's loudoun
county school board meeting
crt is not an honest dialogue is a
tactic that was used by hitler and the
klu klux klan
on slavery's very many years ago to dumb
down my ancestors
so we could not think for ourselves crt
is racist it is abusive it discriminates
against one's color
let me educate you an honest dialogue
does not impress oh press
an honest dialogue does not implement
hatred or injustice it's to communicate
with deceiving
without deceiving people today we don't
need your agreement we want action in
the backbone
for what we asked for today to ban crt i
had to come down here today to tell you
to your face that we are coming together
and we are
strong this will not be the last greet
and meet
respectfully oh
yeah the woman you just saw is called
chantel cooper and
she deserves an award someone please
give her
an award critical race theory is
racist said chantal cooper and she's
absolutely right
it certainly is racist it is obviously
aggressively
flamboyantly racist hurting people
because of their skin color
is the entire point of critical race
theory there is no other point of it
and yet it is now federal policy last
month the department of education
proposed a regulation that directs tax
dollars to the race hustlers
who traffic in this poison the
administration
specifically cited the work of ibrahim
kendi real name henry rogers
as well as the entirely fraudulent 1619
project headed by
nicole hannah jones so what are these
people like
what we're going to show you this show
has just obtained a clip an event held a
few days ago by the oregon department of
education
nicole hannah jones spoke at that event
along with a portland state professor
called ethan johnson who supposedly
chairs the school's black studies
department
according to this ethan johnson and you
may be surprised to learn this
slavery is still going
one of the things that is really
important i think is
to not frame um slavery as a legacy
but as it's still here um
it's legacy suggests that its own rule
there's some remnants of it moving
forward
and i would suggest that no slavery is
right here the idea of what a slave is
is still here
and we're living that
okay so the civil war never happened
turns out that your ancestors weren't
killed or maimed trying to end slavery
abraham lincoln never signed the
emancipation proclamation slavery
is still underway that's the view of
some guy who's literally claiming to be
a college
professor but he's not alone people like
that are in charge of the schools now
low iq vandals wrecking what they did
not build from the very bottom to the
very top they are
everywhere we can give you endless
examples here's just one because it
happened just hours ago
the state of california has announced
its new mathematics
framework for students across the state
our biggest state
one of the authors of this framework is
a stanford professor called joe bowler
here's how she explained the plan these
are her words quote i'm very pleased to
announce the new mathematics framework
for california some highlights
a strong social justice orientation
all students should take the same
courses kindergarten through 10th grade
viva la math revolution right
numbers are racist kill them it's lunacy
it's the french revolution the stuff is
everywhere
have you ever taken a look at the books
that your kids are being assigned in
school have you actually read them
parents in loudoun county actually did
read them and one mother had the
temerity to read portions of those books
allowed
at the loudoun county school board
meeting watch
jasper wasn't even my boyfriend just
this dude i did some hacking with once
in a while
he was pretty basic library systems low
security
not in my league at all but he had a big
and sometimes a girl just needs a big
her top lip curled up wait a minute is
that what's really going on
she did your homework and you ate her
is that why you're crying it's okay it's
cool
this is what girls do at parties i told
myself and kept dancing with the boy
i couldn't see the alcohol making my
waist
wind faster if this is inappropriate for
me to read to you
this is inappropriate for our children
how much did the billion dollar porn
industry
contributed to lcps my question is now
are you going to use the whole language
approach
to coincide with this vial reading and
teach pole dancing
in pe
no that was not to kill a mockingbird
with scout and boo radley
that's racist what you just heard were
excerpts from
anti-racist books that have been
officially approved by loudoun county
teachers
here's a man called brandon michonne
trying to read
more from those books daring to read
aloud from the books
that louden county children are told to
read
watch how they try and shut him up as he
does
i'm going to read an excerpt from a
freshman honors
english class in stonebridge she's a hoe
just like her sister every dude on the
courts
it's time for lcps to get their ax and
their house and order
the curtain has been pulled back and
people can now see the deficient
leadership that's been in this county
my five-year-old is being peddled
transgender books in her library
teenagers are being served pornography
under the guise of young adult
literature
do something be a leader
because if you know what the citizens of
this county deserve better
and if you're not willing to do it can
you please cover your nose with your
mouth you're all vaccinated what the f
what the freak give me 10 seconds back
give me 10 seconds back
there you know the rules thank you
wear your mask when you criticize us
it's a pandemic
in the end they just cut off his mic hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else